here's the thing you need to know for a
fact
if you address
the right problem
okay
you will get results
if you treat the wrong problem
you won't get results
wow
that's heavy but it's idiotically simple
but
you'd be surprised how many people
keep treating the wrong problem for
years without any results so you have to
be willing to try something new and
realize what you're doing is not working
especially with shoulder pain so i'm
going to show you the best position to
sleep with your shoulder because i've
been through a lot of shoulder pain for
years in fact i fractured my left
shoulder i fractured my left elbow and i
had to cope with that trying to sleep so
i'm going to show you the best position
but i want to let you know something
about 80
of shoulder pain
is not coming from the shoulder
it's being referred
and the only reason i figured it out
is being in practice for about 30 years
taking money from people that came in to
get help with their shoulder pain and
then finding out it didn't work so i had
to do everything possible to try
different things to think outside the
box and i'm going to show you some
really great
tips based on years of trial and error
most shoulder pain even if it's on the
left side mostly on the right side
and i'm talking about right up through
here it can be actually through here it
could be in your neck
is coming from not necessarily
gallbladder it's the tube or it's called
a duct between the gallbladder and your
liver
this little tube is called the bile duct
and that duct very commonly becomes
plugged up with a sludge maybe with very
very tiny little stones
but usually not it's usually like a
thick
sludge
and that pressure backs up into the
liver and it backs up into
the diaphragm and causes pressure into
something called the phrenic nerve and
the phrenic nerve goes right up into
your neck right through here and when
that nerve is irritated it causes a
spasm
in your shoulder and it can even cause
the vertebra to rotate and pinch the
nerve right into your shoulder and it
can also happen on the left side too
because the duct also communicates to
the pancreas too
so if there's backup in that duct that
goes in the pancreas it can also affect
the left side
of your diaphragm where there's also a
phrenic nerve that comes up on this side
so if you don't know that
and you're trying to fix your shoulder
and you're doing therapy and you're
doing exercise and you're wondering why
it's not getting better guess what it's
coming from your diet and so if you're
not familiar with keto organic fasting
you definitely need to get on that
immediately to help reduce the pressure
on the digestion because a high carb
diet refined carbs
foods high in omega-6 fatty acids that
would be a lot of nuts that would be a
lot of fried foods those foods will
really irritate
that little duct and cause shoulder pain
all day long and so one little
way to know if your problem is
that duct is just to gently massage
underneath the right rib cage
or the left rib cage about an inch off
the midline just massage that area and
see if your shoulder pain doesn't
completely disappear
at least temporarily if it does chances
are your problem is being referred
by your digestive system
so i just want to bring that up as the
first thing i want to talk about since
it's so common and hardly anyone knows
about it and it's such an easy problem
to fix you're going to probably need
some purified bile salts or a
gallbladder formula i put a link down
below for more information on that but
that will start to thin the bile
allow the flow of bile through that duct
and eliminate the pain in the shoulder
which i have a lot of experience with
because i had shoulder pain for about 12
years before i figured it out the
gallbladder related
problem will cause
tension
in the trap up through here
either side
around the back part where your rhomboid
muscles are
or underneath the trapezius muscle
addressing a muscle that's called the
levator angular scapula because it
levers the
scapula
at a certain angle and apparently it'll
make that muscle so hard uh like a knot
and you'll be massaging that thing to
the cows come home it's never going to
be relieved because the problem is down
here between your gallbladder and your
liver all right so now let's say the
problem is in your shoulder okay you
have arthritis in your ac joint or
somewhere else in your shoulder joint
there is a video that i did on shoulder
pain which is very very powerful as far
as the best exercise to do for shoulder
pain and it's simple hanging okay an
orthopedic surgeon wrote an amazing book
on this one exercise and he claimed that
over 80 to 90 of surgeries were
unnecessary and if you did this exercise
you can avoid the surgery and i i do it
on a regular basis it works and so
you're just going to find some pull-up
bar that you can hang from
initially you don't have to have your
whole body hanging you just need to
stretch your arm either one at a time or
both
and you can just be standing but you
want to stretch this muscle down here
this is called the latissimus dorsi okay
you want to stretch the lat doing that
is going to send
information up to the top part of the
muscles to relax the trap muscles it's
also going to open up the shoulder joint
enough
to allow a lot of relief into your
shoulders so if you were to hang um
let's say after dinner or before bed
for
15 seconds whether it's weight bearing
or not weight bearing it's going to give
your shoulder a lot of relief and you're
going to be able to sleep a lot better
but you want to work up to a situation
where you can
hang with your whole body weight hanging
okay with your hands
forward on a bar
for about 15 to 30 seconds okay you want
to work up to that and then do maybe
three sets of that about three times a
week if you can achieve that your
shoulders are going to be in really good
shape and the other point i want to
bring up is inflammation in general
if you have arthritis or inflammation in
your shoulder joints especially
if you just reflect back on what you ate
yesterday
chances are there's something that you
ate that's causing the inflammation
it could be dairy
it could be some new keto ice cream that
you bought because it was keto friendly
but it had all sorts of ingredients
that created inflammation
or it could be maybe you ate nuts the
day before and all those nuts are high
in omega-6 fatty acids and that created
the inflammation it could have been some
carbohydrate that you ate but usually
there's something you ate the day before
that you probably shouldn't have eaten
but very importantly
reducing omega-6 fatty acids and
increasing the omega-3 fatty acids from
fish oils or olive oil is going to be
essential one of the best
natural
remedies
for inflammation in general that i found
is called stinging nettle root it's a
really good remedy for inflammation if
you just have arthritis in general and
you've already addressed the diet and of
course the combination of keto
intermittent fasting is going to be
essential if you're new to my channel i
put a link down below that'll probably
get rid of your shoulder pain right away
because it's going to drop inflammation
especially the intermittent fasting
because fasting drops inflammation and
the most powerful vitamin that can help
you with inflammation
is vitamin d3
if you get the combination of d3
with vitamin k2
you're going to have a really good
combination because vitamin k2
takes the calcium buildup from your
arteries and your joints and it puts it
back into the bone so it helps to remove
calcium
that shouldn't be in certain places and
the vitamin d3
drops inflammation dramatically so
you're going to actually feel a lot
better when you take at least 20 000
iu's a vitamin d3
with the ratio of about 20 micrograms of
k2 so for every 10 000 iu's of d3 you
need a hundred micrograms
of k2 that would be the ratio that you
want to look at and if you have shoulder
pain when you're sleeping
just take this vitamin d3 k2 blend
right before bed because it will also
help you sleep and i have some
information on that in the description
down below all right now let's get into
the position
of how not to sleep okay
so if you're going to sleep on your side
with all your pressure on your shoulder
joint itself
that's going to be very uncomfortable
because there's too much pressure and
weight on your shoulder so what you want
to do is not sleep directly on the
shoulder you want to tuck the shoulder
in
about two inches forward so that's tip
number one now at the same time you want
to make sure that your head
is neutral with your spine you don't
want your head too far down or too far
up so you're gonna have to adjust the
pillow another thing that i recommend is
taking a very small
towel or even a washcloth and rolling it
up and putting it underneath your neck
so that way it supports and takes some
pressure off the shoulder if the
shoulder is painful as well as rolling
up a small towel or a washcloth and
putting it underneath the rib cage okay
so right about here
so now we can actually raise the
position
below and above the shoulder so there's
virtually no pressure on the shoulder
itself and it's also important as you're
sleeping not to have your head too
forward
or to backwards but to have it
completely neutral
on the pillow it's definitely worth it
to spend some money and buy
a high quality pillow and it's really an
individual choice so what i do is i
might go to a store
and i will just
sample out a lot of different pillows
until i find the one
that is perfect and i'm not even going
to look at the price tag because
i mean think about this you spend a
third of your life in bed so it's
definitely worth it to get the right
pillow
some people like it firm some people
like it thick and
what's good for your spouse might not be
good for you
so invest
in the best pillow you can find now what
about sleeping in your stomach
terrible
why
well just go ahead and turn your head to
the right side right now just go ahead
and turn your head and then hold that
position for eight hours
okay that's what happens when you sleep
now you're going to probably go to the
left side the right side but when you
you cannot sleep with your face in the
pillow you have to turn your neck and
holding your neck into that position is
going to
cut off the nerve supply to your
brachial plexus of nerves and guess
where those nerves go they go into the
shoulder
not good
so you don't want to sleep on your
stomach okay or even if with your arms
up like this because you're going to
obstruct the nerves in your in your uh
shoulder and they go right down the arm
all right and the other position that i
don't recommend is sleeping on your back
on a pillow or without a pillow with
your hands underneath your head
not a good position because again it's
going to pinch off the nerves
through your neck that go right into
your shoulder not a good idea the
absolute best position is on your side
with a pillow
which brings your head up to a nice
neutral position
so you with your head not too forward
not too back with your shoulders
slightly tucked forward about two inches
maybe with another rolled towel
underneath your neck or a washcloth and
underneath your shoulder right on the
rib cage so you're positioning your
shoulder with the least amount of
pressure on it i also recommend a pillow
between your knees
so your lower back and hips are not a
problem and of course then you want to
through the night position yourself
maybe on the other shoulder back and
forth now if you have not seen my video
on how the gallbladder can refer pain to
the shoulder
since it's so common
i put that video right here check it out